okay welcome to this video playing Jimmy
the saint and no info in there okay we
got an English opening something else
for a change he defended with c5 them
the symmetrical variation and now if I
yeah this is a very solid line that
gives black quite decent play the gap
the board Winnick setup c5e five is very
very reliable black has some very decent
equalizing chances here normally black
plays with a five now trying to prevent
before okay so he allowed me to play
before that in most cases something that
why does some glad to have achieved okay
I'm regrouping my night aiming for the
important d 5 square
yeah Bishop h3 this is quite often p
resource I can do this however and now
Bishop f3 there is b5 and this is
technically quite unlucky for black I
was thinking be five is good now isn't
it b5 okay Bishop g2 this B takes c6 and
that looks rather nice for wide the
night cannot move due to 97 check and
Bishop h3 I was thinking that 95 should
prevent bishop 83 but yeah I guess he
didn't really think about the move
Bishop g2 be takes c6 queen age 397
czech teen age 8 and probably just rupee
one and i'm ultimately appies up I don't
really think that he can do something on
my admittedly bid we at King position
with the Queen on age three yeah I think
he just he chooses a piece now
I don't see I don't see how he saves a
material here black resigns no that's
just a piece ready yeah this is the key
point that this is winning a tempo on
the Queen so we cannot retreat the
bishop or something I mean this check
this can be tried the only question now
is what is the most precise continuation
now i also have c7 possibly it's a
symbol let's check this now that's
probably the easiest origin that just
promote him then turn something just a
piece up here for for a pawn and also
get the fantastic square there yeah
missionary was really just a blunder
here he has to play normal move
something computer is suggesting to take
then db5 yeah that looks that looks good
actually interesting interesting try
based on the this technical point this
is hanging yeah and it's okay yeah b5 it
just uses a piece oh yeah okay
interesting thanks for watching